the prophet sallam then concluded that
hadith on the strange
uh the strangeness he said uh you know
islam began as something strange
meaning that in mecca when it began
uh the prophet sallam and his companions
were very few and
their situation at that time is just
like our situation today
they were looked at as strangers like
who are these guys
what are they doing uh they're going
against the norms
they're going against our ways
the ways of our forefathers and so they
were looked at as being strange
and then the prophet sallam said it will
once again
return to being something strange
meaning that there will come a time
when islam will become dominant and
you know that strangeness will go away
and that happened in the time of the
sahaba
and for many centuries until there will
come a time when that strangeness will
come back and we
are without a doubt witnessing that
today and then he concluded the hadith
by saying
then give glad tidings to the strangers
and so this is a message to us basically
that you know uh remain a stranger
you know remain a stranger uh
the process of someone is giving us glad
tidings and
uh you know whenever the prophet saws
gives glad tidings that means janna
[Music]
[Music]
um
so my eyes character is uh think about a
video game think about a movie you think
about a book
you have different characters the
character
is uh the expressions the actions
the personality the traits of this
individual
good character would imply obviously
that this person leads
towards good bad would imply that they
lean towards bad but
having character in general uh implies
authenticity or at least
i would say good character implies
authenticity
and welcome back to the with us podcast
in the dunya
you join today with the three regular
host of three muslims and we are joined
today with sheikh
salam
let me ask were you born in canada where
we currently live
uh yes i was born here in toronto
toronto so what was toronto like perhaps
20 30 years ago before i was born
uh toronto was um
uh not not too different but
from a lot of angles uh things were very
different
uh um i would say
like i grew up in the in the late 80s
and throughout the 90s and
things were not like they are today in
the sense of
the spread of islam i would say
islam was starting to spread in terms of
you know uh us muslims being a visible
minority
we were not i wouldn't say we were a
visible minority then but
um today we are like almost wherever you
go
in the gta uh you find muslims uh in
those days it wasn't like that
uh even if muslims were concentrated in
certain areas even then like um uh
you couldn't tell that you know we were
a visible minority
um growing up uh
you know we're talking about free
internet age
um you know
forget about social media there wasn't
even any internet
and so things were much different
um then obviously with the internet age
and information age and then social
media
okay subhanallah so my next question i
think like this question is begged
the pros and cons of living as a muslim
back then
in toronto or in the in the west in
general versus the pros and cons
of living as a muslim today in the west
what would you say those are uh
to be honest um uh
muslims living in the west whether it
was back then
or whether it is today uh we still face
the same
uh issues and the same obstacles
practicing islam growing up here
in the west in the sense that
[Music]
many muslims are you know still
want to hide their identity they don't
want to stand out
they don't want to be seen as muslims
they want to fit in a lot of peer
pressure like those things have not
changed
what has changed i would say is um
[Music]
there being more uh opportunities for
the youth
uh you know in terms of more massages
more uh centers more activities
you know uh the youth have you know more
places to go uh to be with the muslims
then in those days in those days it was
it was difficult uh and um
you know maybe you would have uh one or
two masjids who
would be doing something like who would
even have a gym for example
so i would say you know um
in that sense today it's better
um but like i said you know the the
the issues are still the same issues
yeah
yeah and i can say that 100 you know
someone who grew up in in these same
places
i myself didn't even start practicing
being a born muslim into a muslim family
i didn't start practicing until 1617 is
because i came across a video on youtube
talking about the gibbs and islam and
all of that and then subhanallah from
from there i
i basically made islam my surroundings
and i went based off that but
you know then that leads me to ask how
many people actually had that experience
because kind of allah all these
different ways of thinking
um that begin with secularism liberalism
are projected onto the muslims these are
things that you know are inherently by
definition
un-islamic and that actually go against
them so
how would you how would you say those
affect the muslim youth and the older
generations today
yeah uh definitely a living
you know i could tell you from my own
experience you know i uh
uh although i grew up here
uh i left canada
at the age of 19. i went to study
and then i spent uh you know the next
you could say 17 years uh abroad
studying uh i could tell you like
you know the huge contrast of
living as a muslim in the west versus
living out as a muslim
in the east now i'm not trying to say
that uh
you know there's no problems in muslim
countries
uh for sure there are you know uh
whenever we talk about the issue of uh
you know uh hijra for example um
migrating to a muslim country uh we get
a lot of
criticism for that uh because it's like
we're trying to say that
you know there's a utopia out there and
all muslims should go
and you know everything will be fine i'm
not saying that you know
muslim countries have their own problems
but i will say that environment plays a
huge role
environment plays a huge role your
surroundings play a huge role
on your identity as a muslim so
when we are here in the west we are
surrounded by as you mentioned
these ideologies liberalism secularism
uh atheism uh feminism etc
and many times we muslim we will pick up
uh aspects of these ideologies without
even realizing without even noticing it
um and that's and that's only because
we are you know in that environment
uh if you were in a muslim environment
you wouldn't
pick those ideologies up uh you wouldn't
pick them up
as easily i'm not saying that you know
we don't have
youth in muslim countries who don't who
have not adopted these ideologies i'm
not saying that
but i'm saying that they're a minority
why because their surroundings play a
huge role
and that's why the famous uh historian
uh even hollywood
who has his famous um uh book
uh he mentions in it
that um
wherever you are or in fact he was
mentioning
in general uh where you have
uh a powerful nation and a powerful
uh dominant uh empire let's say
uh civilization uh those who are
inferior the other civilizations the
other nations that are inferior
their people will look up to uh the more
superior nation
and civilization and they will follow in
their footsteps
and they will imitate them and they will
want to be like them
so that is the case today uh
muslims around the world in fact we are
not
superior we have this inferiority
complex and so
um we want to be like the west
we want to adopt many of their you know
ways of life
and so imagine if you're living in that
in the midst of that environment
such as here in the west you're going to
pick up these
these islamic ideologies
without noticing it and then you're
going to try to
somehow
try to bridge between these ideologies
and that's what we're seeing
unfortunately the muslims the vast
majority of them here in the west
uh want to practice an islam that
somehow mixes between
western culture and their islam
and you know the reality is that
islam has its own way of life and
[Music]
you know many aspects of western culture
and civilization
are completely anti-islam we have to say
it as it is
uh we're not saying that you know we
can't take the good
from from that civilization we take the
good as long as it doesn't contradict
uh what our deen uh teaches us
yeah yeah so habibi what was it like
living in a muslim country
versus over here in the west
uh well like i said um
when you're in a muslim country you're
surrounded by muslims
let's forget about you know uh the fact
that
you know islam is not being implemented
the way it should be
uh and instead you have man-made laws in
almost every single muslim country
uh so and you have aspects of islamic
laws
you know uh being implemented but you
know the reality is that the shariah
is not uh being implemented uh
anywhere in any muslim country the way
it should be
uh forget about the muslim rulers forget
about uh
you know that aspect just the fact that
you are
uh around surrounded by muslims you have
masajid
you have the azan being called uh
wherever you go
your your greeting muslims muslims are
greeting you wherever you go
you have you know halal meet you have uh
restaurants
uh you don't have these issues that we
face
uh here uh as muslims where we are
surrounded by the opposite
we are surrounded by the kuffar we are
surrounded by kufur
uh and so that aspect of
of of islam uh that aspect of
you know you practicing your deen we
could we could call it the
the social aspect the social aspect of
practicing islam uh is much easier there
is is much much easier there and uh
as for the other aspects like i said uh
you know
uh we're not talking about that but uh
just that aspect um it basically
gives you a sense of identity as i said
where
uh you know
you don't feel strange you don't feel
like a stranger
uh but rather you are a part of this
you are a part of this woman and i
remember uh growing up
um my background is uh
is pakistani and my parents used to make
it a point to take us back
uh to visit pakistan when we were very
very young when we were kids
and i realized that that
played a huge role in me you know
wanting to later on uh go and
you know live among among muslims in a
muslim country
uh and the reason for that is because of
that bond that was you know uh
that that that was being uh built there
for me
you know and then later on later on i
look at my
you know some of my friends who didn't
have that opportunity
who grew up here and not once did they
leave canada
or the west they lost that
and today they have no interest they
have absolutely no interest
for going to a muslim country i'm
talking about even the ones who later on
start practicing
so they're practicing muslims but they
don't feel that that that
need to identify themselves with the
ummah you know that that
that uh that that that feeling of you
know you belong to an ummah
was built for me from a young age why
because i saw
i saw you know my muslim brothers and
sisters uh in other muslim countries
uh when you're living in the west you
yes i mean we living in the west
we're living in a very multicultural
uh environment where you have muslims
from around the world here
but it's completely different to go and
actually visit those places
and to see those places and when it's
done from a young age
uh it uh you know builds that sense of
that sense of um in in in the muslim
[Music]
so when did you go out there to start
studying
uh this was in i would say the year 2002
yeah so 2002 i went
uh i went with my father for hajj and
then
um from there i went
to egypt and my father returned to
canada
and yeah and then i spent some time in
egypt learning arabic
and then i went to i went to saudi
i spent some time in riyadh
and then from there i went to medina
spending
about eight years in medina
and then after that i went on to a
different university in saudi
in a place called qasim kasim
is approximately 500 kilometers
east of medina closer to riyadh
and it's known for a place that has
produced a lot
of scholars uh that was the hometown
of uh sheikh ibn rothaming
who passed uh passed away about 20 years
ago
and so i did my master's there and uh
yeah i spent about seven years there
seven eight years there and then i came
back
awesome yeah that's
that's a long time that you were doing
your studies
i was just about to ask about that what
was it like do you recommend that people
go study there what was education in the
timeline like
yeah uh
[Music]
definitely if one wants to go to study i
would advise
that they pursue um
what we can call traditional learning uh
with academic learning uh
and so you know traditional learning
what i mean by that is
going and studying under the scholars
sitting at the feet of the scholars
studying under them uh traditionally
uh you know the various classical books
academic learning is you know the
university style
where you have a structured program that
you go through etc
someone who combines these two ways uh
obviously
with a sincere intention uh there is no
doubt that
you know he will he he is basically
treading the path of the scholars
and uh if he works hard enough he will
become a scholar
so yeah i would i would definitely
advise anyone who wants to go to study
but
uh you know they should do so obviously
uh things have changed dramatically uh
in saudi in terms of uh you know the
the the course that they're going in
uh currently and so that has affected uh
the universities the the the
um the learning the studying uh
[Music]
where unfortunately many of
the scholars have been imprisoned uh
many other scholars
have been banned from teaching uh
these same scholars i'm talking about
were out and we benefited from them
uh you know over the course
of the last uh you know uh 15 years or
so
wow
so the curriculum change yeah and the
curriculum they're saying
uh they're saying uh it will be it will
be
changing as well uh i
i have not seen that i mean i left
before all of these major changes
uh but from what i'm hearing uh you know
that's what they're saying okay so
question
you have someone who's studying islam
they're going deep into their studies
but they haven't
done the actual proper studies
underneath the
the scholars and then you have someone
who has and then
they become a scholar is there a big
difference
in terms of their studies in terms of
their intellect in terms of uh
where they're getting everything from or
would you say it's roughly the same it's
just this one is accredited
because it's underneath the scholars
while this one is not accredited so they
can't
claim to be a sheikh or a scholar
uh look uh when it comes to uh
scholarship in islam
it's not by how much you study it's not
by how many degrees you have how many
certificates you have
how many jazzas you have it's not about
how many scholars
you could name as being your teachers
it's not about how long
how many years you've studied uh it all
goes back to
uh the tawfiq of allah at the end of the
day
allah subhanahu wa choosing a person to
become a scholar
and that happens through
two ways with regards to the person
and these two ways are firstly having
their sincere intention having a
loss and this is one of the most
difficult things for the student of
knowledge
because many times the student wants to
go out
on this path of seeking knowledge
because he sees
other you know scholars or
and you know they have status they're
looked up to
some of them are celebrity scholars
and so they want to become like them
they say okay this is what i want to
become
so they leave their home on the path of
seeking knowledge and this is their
intention
this is a corrupt intention they'll
never become scholar like that
because you know the intention from the
very beginning was for the sake of the
dunya
so the first thing as i said is
sincerity of intention the second thing
is hard work a person can be as sincere
as he wants but maybe he's lazy
and you know he sleeps all day and he
doesn't put in
the effort the effort comes in as i said
through two ways academic learning and
traditional learning so those who were
with us who studied with us
you had some who had put more emphasis
on their academic studies
and they would pass all their exams
they would you know uh they were they
would always be
getting uh you know uh the top marks in
class and whatnot
but they wouldn't go out of their way
outside of the university to study on
those scholars
and so they became what we could call
academics you know today they're they're
academics they're
they're good at researching they're good
at uh
you know um writing papers
that's good i mean i'm not i'm not you
know badmouthing them i'm not saying
that
this is not needed in our um but
i wouldn't call them uh scholars
we wouldn't call them scholars in the
islamic definition
western definition of a scholar is
someone who has a phd right
but that's not the case in islam we
don't we don't call
a phd holder an iralim a scholar
but rather an adam is
someone who has mastered all of the
islamic sciences
we're talking about you know all of them
you know from al qaeda to hadith to phil
uh the arabic language
uh the quran all of that he's mastered
them
uh he's memorized these various mutual
these various classical
uh books and uh
and an important ingredient for for
being
that is uh
uh is action you know being
a scholar who practices who practices
what he preaches
who practices the knowledge that allah
has given to him and that's where many
fall short
you know that's one of the most
difficult things after
the intention the intention is very
difficult and then
uh also putting into practice the
knowledge
that you have
what's it
all right bro
anything that popped into my mind was
when you came back
to the west what were some things that
initially
you know just hit you and you were just
like you got that little bit of a
cognitive dissonance things that you
know when you were here you were a
little bit desensitized to
and then you really noticed it when you
came back
uh
that's a really good question because um
uh
that was the very first thing i
addressed in my very first quote
when i came back uh and that is
uh just uh the the sins
that surround us in in
in this environment uh
me coming from that environment
uh where you know uh i didn't
see these things although i grew up with
them i mean it wasn't something that
came to me like you know like oh my god
what is this
i'm not talking about that kind of
reaction but just the
the idea that wow i'm back in this filth
again
and the reason why i addressed it i
chose to address this topic in my very
first khutbah
is because i knew that
the majority of the muslims are
desensitized
to many of these sins and to much of the
filth that's out there
we're desensitized to it because we're
living in it and we become accustomed to
it
and i knew that
before long i will also become
desensitized to it
so let me address it now uh before
before that happens so i remember i
addressed it
and
[Music]
being aware of uh becoming uh
desensitized to
to the sins that are around us and
uh to the fields that surround us and
after the
the brothers they said we decided not to
to to live stream the corp and to take
it off because
it was uh you know they felt it was a
bit too
uh too reactionary or too
too hard and it might get them in
trouble
and and yeah so uh
you know i i feel that uh even until now
i feel that these are issues that we
need to actually be speaking about
and the reason for that is because
if you have uh our imams
and our habibs
only speaking about let's say
you know doing doing good deeds uh
getting closer to allah through
different acts of very bad etc
uh without pointing out without pointing
out
the dangers that we live in then
the muslims you know they'll never wake
up
they'll think that you know their
surroundings you know
the field that's out there it's
completely okay
uh they're already desensitized to it
they're already accustomed to it
don't think it's not a big deal and
that's a reality that we live in
uh where you know uh you have many
muslims
like our sisters for example who
uh you know they have a certain attire
certain type of hijab
that they believe is completely okay
um they think that the hijab only means
a
piece of cloth on your head when
you know uh and and you could wear
anything underneath
some of them think that um as long as my
skin is covered
i can wear whatever i want and they wear
the tightest of clothes
and the prophet salallahu had a warned
of a time
that will come when when there will be
women
who will who will be clothed they'll be
wearing clothes but they're naked
and the small as they interpret that to
me that they're wearing skin-tight
clothes
and the prophet saw he cursed such
women he cursed them so i'm just
mentioning this as an example
one small example uh otherwise
you know the examples are many
it makes me think about what brother
fire says where it's like shaytaan
works in steps and like let's say
you have music playing in the background
and this is just part of the culture and
you grow up
there's always music all around you
maybe your parents are like oh
don't listen music but you're
exposed to it and after a while you're
going to be
listening to it and then you're going to
become desensitized to it
and this all happens in in baby steps
you know so it's like let's say uh you
get a
fresh muslim from uh the east
a muslim country they come over here to
the west
you play them a song in which it's
talking about
sex drugs and killing people and they'll
be like oh stop for allah
stuck for a lot like turn that off i
don't want to hear anything like that
you have a born muslim and i'm i'm not
trying to generalize everything but this
is
for the example the thought experiment
here you have a born muslim they've been
exposed to this they are desensitized so
now they can hear this song
and it'll be playing in the background
but it won't even
they're not even reacting to it to them
they feel like ah you know what
i'm not listening to it i'm not uh
acknowledging
what's being said like this isn't what i
listen to is in the music
but it's it's playing you're allowing it
to be in the background
because you've become desensitized to it
it's because of those steps that this
person went through
then now they are open to this versus
the muslim that's like coming from the
east like he hears that he's like oh
stuff for allah he's going to get
out of that environment he doesn't want
to be anywhere near that
so that's very true and that is how
shaitaan works
he doesn't he doesn't come to you right
away uh
you know he doesn't come to you and say
commit zina uh
but rather he starts with the gaze and
that's why
allah azzawajal uh commanded
us to lower our gaze somebody may think
what's a big deal just a look it's
something so small
but that's where it starts from and uh
that's why in the quran
did not say do not commit
zina
allah did not say don't commit zina but
don't even come near it
meaning those baby steps those steps of
shaytan
and also what i said
do not follow in the footsteps of
shaytan
why did allah call it the footsteps
because that's
you know that's exactly what it is you
know shaytan that's how he drags us
uh into committing those sins and so uh
that's how sins they they they
they destroy us um
and that's why uh the scholars say that
um the minor sins that we look at
as being insignificant as being small
not a big deal
when they pile up and we uh are
persistent in those sins
they are equal to a major sin
they are no different to a major sin
if we continuously persist in that sin
and we don't care about it and we don't
you know ask allah to forgive us for
those sins
and let me tell you something man before
i became muslim
about a year ago alhamdulillah
i had i had a very bad issue
with my my sexual desire
uh with women how pornography and stuff
like that i
actually went through this um they they
call it nofap
the kuffar called it nofap where you you
stop doing everything
for x amount of time and it's like after
that time frame you can choose to
continue or you can choose to just
go right back to watching pornography
and you know touching yourself and all
that stuff
one of the things that i realized when i
was doing this after failing repeatedly
over and over and over and over again
is that if i didn't lower my gaze
it just it led to this snowball effect
where it ultimately led into me
relapsing and watching pornography
and it's like now that i'm on dean now
it's like
oh i see it i see the truth
it says it in the quran where it's like
lower your gaze and this is something
that i was realizing just from
going through those motions
[Music]
yeah uh and that i think that's what you
know even
now psychologists that's what they say
that you need to
cut it out from the root and you need to
completely stay away from it
and there is no way to stay away from it
uh
except by lowering the gigs and that's
the first step
and as uh he says that
uh the site our site is basically
the arrow the arrow uh
that shaitan uses to to
to hit or hurt and that's how he comes
to us
let's be honest how does
a man i'm not even gonna say a young man
because this this is for every single
man
how does a man lower his gaze especially
here in the west
you guys you guys know for sure
how difficult it is over here
yeah definitely i gave a football on
this a
few weeks ago maybe it was uh
in the beginning of the summer uh
specifically for that reason because the
summer was coming
and it was important to address it
uh basically
there's no doubt that there is no
uh there is no better way
to do it except by realizing the
greatness of allah
when you realize the greatness of allah
and who allah is
uh you will
you know have that consciousness of
allah that allah is watching
and that's why in the ayah where allah
commands us to lower our gaze
what does allah say how does he end the
ayah and this is something i
i want to share with you guys that the
quran
is definitely miraculous and
you know uh one of its uh miraculous
uh aspects is the ending of the ayat
why does allah end certain ayat with
certain attributes
and names of him subhanahu wa
there's a secret behind each ayah so in
that ayah
uh you know tell the believing men
say to the believing men that they
should lower their gaze
and guard their private parts that is
purer and better for them
the one who knows well aware and the
scholars say the difference between
so ali means the one who knows as well
right
ali means the one who has knowledge
khabib also
it has that same meaning but the
difference between the two
is that khabib is someone who
knows something very well and that's why
in the arabic language
you say um to someone who's a specialist
in something that he is
that he is he's a specialist
he's killed at this particular thing
and in the quran allah only uses khabib
to mention his knowledge of things that
otherwise
are unknown to most people so when allah
says
that he is well aware of what you do it
is signaling to us
that yes you'll be looking at those
women
thinking that those around you your
friends
didn't know what you were looking at but
[Music]
so you you you secretly take a glance
and you're with your friends they didn't
know
but allah is telling you he knew and so
inculcating that idea of the greatness
of allah
that allah is watching me that is
there is no better way for us to help
ourselves to lower our
days and allah's best
i think a big issue and i'm gonna speak
for
uh reverts because i don't know if it's
the same for boring muslims
over here in the west but i grew up with
this uh
thing where i was taught is like you
should
look at people in the eyes you should
look
at people and acknowledge them and um
i was also taught that like i should
look at women and if i
lowered my gaze from women it was either
one that i was gay or two
that i was weak and it's like
now i have this the quran and my own
experience
from what i told you when i was trying
to get rid of the pornography addiction
was like look lowering the gaze
allah has decreed it for us and my
experiences
showed me that lowering the gaze is
essential
but then i have like this this uh
different narrative that i was taught
that's like over here battling all the
time where it's like i see
a woman obviously my natural sexual
desires my inclinations and this other
narrative is over here like
look look look at her acknowledge the
presence
get attention talk to her go do this go
do that but it's like
man it's a huge battle and again i'm
gonna speak for reverse here and i don't
know if that if
if it's like that for uh boring muslim
men
yeah yeah it's a struggle and uh you
know
uh we just need to uh continue that
struggle
and you know not not give up bro
so in the last few minutes um i feel
like
this is something i wanted to mention
earlier about angel some really really
uh
good questions about allah um i feel
it's important to mention some practical
examples of things that
we believe that were propagated by the
west that we see
as normal right this just being one of
them you know the gays the glance
um having you know boys girls mixed
together men and women mixed together
not
segregating these are things that like
if we call for segregation like we're
we're weirdos basically right the same
way if
um if even if a woman wants to be a
housewife nowadays it's like that's
weird
right polygeny is like you don't even
say the word nowadays
but even things like mortgages right
this is something that islamically is
not coherent
but it's so normalized and it's that we
have you know
a different fatwas being given that are
saying
that i'm not here to give any fatwa i'm
not a scholar right i'm not but we have
different faculty saying that you know
you can get a mortgage
right in this scenario that scenario and
um
that the prophet at least also he
actually said that in a hadith
that there will come a time where
muslims look to make
men wearing silk alcohol zina
musical instruments and he names some
things they look to make these things
halal
and this is what we're seeing nowadays
because of the west and a few different
hadith
popped up in my head for example the
prophet
he said that islam began as something
strange and it will
return to something strange and that's
exactly what we're experiencing
feeling authorized alienated like like
we are the weird ones we're strange
people
because we don't adopt certain practices
that these people adopt
and the other hadith of the prophet
islam said that
basically there will come a time where
muslims follow the non-believers
so closely that if the the non-believer
put his hand in the lizard's hole
the muslim would also put his hand in
that lizard's hole
and and exactly one hill is saying you
know non-muslims are saying
don't lower your gays look at the
muslims and inevitably when a muslim
does that he's putting himself in that
same lizards hold because it opens up
all these problems that
every single man nowadays has uh has to
face
concluded that hadith on the strange uh
the strangeness
he said uh you know islam began as
something strange
meaning that in mecca when it began
uh the prophet sallam and his companions
were very few
and their situation at that time
is just like our situation today they
were looked at
as strangers like who are these guys
what are they doing
uh they're going against the norms
they're going against
our ways the ways of our forefathers
and so they were looked at as being
strange and then the prophet sallam said
it will once again return to being
something strange meaning
that there will come a time when islam
will become dominant
and you know that strangeness will go
away and that happened in the time of
the sahaba
and for many centuries until there will
come a time when that strangeness will
come back
and we are without a doubt witnessing
that today and then he concluded the
hadith by saying
then give glad tidings to the strangers
and so this is a message to us basically
that you know uh remain a stranger
you know remain a stranger uh
the process of someone is giving us glad
tidings
and uh you know whenever the prophet
saws gives glad tidings that means
jannah
it basically means janna whether it's
mentioned in the quran or in the sunnah
glad tidings means uh it basically means
jannah
absolutely beautiful
um unfortunately unfortunately this
episode's coming to an end but there's
one big question that i do want to ask
um it may have been addressed early in
this video but that question is
we are we're strangers right as the
prophet islam islam said and may allah
grants to jannah for it
living in this time how do we hold on to
her dean as a prophet
said that there will come a time where
holding unto your deen will be like
holding on to
hot coals how do we hold on to our deen
yeah so basically uh
you know it is difficult uh in the times
in which we're living in
and uh you know the way to do it
is by uh
first and foremost seeking as much
knowledge as we can
because if we remain ignorant
then we're going to fall into into those
traps you know uh
without knowing secondly
uh by implementing whatever we've
learned
and thirdly and this is something very
important uh
by being around good company
by being in good company uh
you know i can't stress that enough uh
you know shape on he comes and he takes
the lone wolf
he is the lone wolf and he takes the
sheep that
uh that basically strays away
from the jamal and so you don't want to
be
that uh that that pray for the lord
for the wolf but rather you want to be
with brothers you want to be in good
company
brothers who advise one another who are
constantly
uh you know telling one another about
allah about
reminding one another about that
without a doubt here in the west uh that
is something uh
that we need uh more than anything else
exactly
so i have one final question unless five
months ago
take it away bro my final question
shake if uh if a man
let's say i'm walking down the street
and this is serious
please don't take this as a joke this is
serious if i'm walking down the street
and i see a woman if i
like if our eyes lock i can smile
and basically acknowledge the presence
but then keep moving on would it
would uh the gays be considered when
you're
when you're basically looking with
sexual lust
uh no uh basically uh
the gaze whether we are it doesn't
matter what kind of
look it is it is haram and that's
because
um you know the various evidences that
we have in the quran and in the sunnah
that the prophet sallam you know
advised us to lower the gaze and
he said i believe
it was to ali that
the first gaze the first gaze
and the first look is for you meaning
you're walking down the street
and you see her so that first sight
is for you meaning it is forgiven it is
pardoned
but then the prophet sallam said as for
the second it is not for you
meaning if you keep looking then now
you're going to be sinful
now you're going to be sinful so we're
excused for the first look because
you know it was unintentional but then
if we
persist in that look even if it is
without lust
uh it is haram because of what it will
do because of what it will do
and so many times we think it as being
harmless uh insignificant and this is
what we spoke about earlier
that you know that's how uh that's how
uh
shaitaan traps us he says oh it's not a
big deal
you know you're not looking with lust uh
keep looking
you know but then where is that going to
take you to
very true that's very true step by step
it's parallel may not protect us all
um on my my final like closing
statements is from my own anecdotal
experience
um like i said i started practicing when
i was like 16 or 17
and i didn't have brothers or like you
know people who would you know say
call allah like you know really remind
me of allah
and have sittings where we just discuss
allah in islam and the prophet
islam i didn't have that what i did have
however
was you know the islamic lectures online
and seeking knowledge and learning
myself
so my advice to the people because i
know there are going to be the people
that say i just don't have anyone like
that i can't find anyone like that
um look for them but until you find them
make this podcast your friend
make the the lecturers and the good pies
people online your friend
and become that person for yourself the
prophet
islam to shall end with this hadith
he said that loneliness is better than
bad company
and good company is better than
loneliness meaning that
it's better to be alone than to be bad
people yes but it is better to be a good
people than be alone
but if you must be alone being alone by
yourself is better than being bad
and you should be that friend um that
that khalil for yourself insha'allah
any final closing statements take it
away brother
all right with that being said it's been
a lovely episode if you want to see
the lovely kamala
is a thing about a video game think
about a movie you think about a book
you have different characters the
character
is uh the expressions the actions
the personality the traits of this
individual
good character would imply obviously
that this person leads
towards good bad would imply that they
lean towards bad but
having character in general uh implies
authenticity or at least
i would say good character implies
authenticity
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]